la pire façon dont vous avez largué
quelqu'un s'était jetée ya très
longtemps adolescents et à l'adolescence
j'avais très peu de succès avec les
filles sauf les allemandes harry
souffler avant ce fait les sharks avec
angela merkel lui pendant d'autres
autres caucase et du nudisme est donc
j'étais dans des camps franco-allemand
de d'adolescents et le verre le lavandin
les jours je suis avec une allemande et
a laissé le moment jamais tout on a
trouvé formidable et on n'était pas
insensible à son charme et on va pour
s'embrasser pour face allemand gm l'asie
à vous inquiéter pas identifié asiatique
ans et depuis vous y avoir un monde trop
dur comment vous salissez ma ma jeunesse
on devait se rouler une pelle et j'ai
compris qu'elle ne savait pas au moment
où elle est venue vers moi n'a fait est
là c'est un peu compliqué que par
politesse je vais comme l'est celle à
moustache
j'assume et plus du tout est resté un
jour et je voulais pas me faire la peine
donc en fait je me suis caché pendant un
jour dans le camp jusqu'au départ nord
est est demandé partout il est loué moi
j'étais caché dans les buissons l étape
la chercher petit à petit
[Applaudissements]